and that is the game exactly and with
both players getting along time this is
any ones game Rook B7 a clever little
trick by Magnus the bishop moves the E2
Bishop B7 if anything it still looks a
little bit uncomfortable for Yan here
and Yankee blunder Bishop if the king
gets out to F2 now oh the Rooks on B6
not on B7 there there goes the backup he
walked into it a different way and the
pawn F5 lives on because of Rook G5 this
is going to be a win for Magnus Carlsen
oh no this looks like game one in
reverse
and Bishop h8 what a great move hanging
on to the bishop okay king of fate and
now you just go Rook A7 followed by F6
wait but you are a little bit stuck
though how exactly do you make progress
rookie seven maybe young can push it
upon the bishop stuck over here but now
Magnus is pushing up his King and there
should be a win yeah it should be the
king can also helper F7 f8